[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to deconstruct world-class
performers from all different walks of
life all different Arenas to tease out
the habits Lessons Learned Etc that you
can apply to your own lives my guest
today long overdue is Mark Manson you
can find him all over the webs including
on Twitter at I am Mark Manson Mark is a
three-time number one New York Times
best-selling author of The subtle art of
not giving a [ __ ] maybe you've heard of
it as well as other titles his books
have sold nearly
2-020 million copies worldwide and have
reached number one in more than a dozen
countries since 2008 he has written
articles at markmanson.net one of the
largest personal development blogs in
the world with more than a million
monthly readers in 2023 a feature film
about him and his work will be released
in theaters by Universal Pictures we'll
link to everything in the show notes as
per usual at tim.blog podcast mark
welcome to the show nice to see you it's
a pleasure happy to be here I read this
profile of you in New York mag
and it shared many different stories and
I want to dig into maybe certain aspects
of that
but what I'd be curious to hear just off
the cuff because a lot has happened in
your life in the last five to seven
years
what have been some of the most
difficult
changes to get accustomed to or default
behaviors to modify now that your
reality has changed
oh man I mean I feel like we could do
the entire show just on this
you know you could do it probably do an
entire episode maybe you could get like
an All-Star guest list of of like what
people don't tell you about success yeah
let's do it the most surprising thing
and the most difficult thing at the same
time was in you know subtlear not giving
a [ __ ] came out in 2016
it hit number one early 2017 and by
mid-2017 it was just Off to the Races I
think it sold like two or three million
copies just that year and
and for me it was very strange I mean
obviously there was a lot of happiness
and joy but for me it was very strange
because as a Young author with their
first traditionally published book I had
all of these long-term goals and dreams
and Visions for myself of like I'm gonna
be writing till I'm 50 and you know
maybe one day I'll be on the times list
and maybe one day I'll you know get
invited on a Morning Show and uh
I hit all those dreams in like three
months basically
and and to my surprise is that there was
just this profound kind of emptiness on
the other side of that of oh [ __ ] what
do I dream now like what what do I hope
for in my future
and so very unexpectedly it kind of I
spiraled into a little bit of a funk
like a little bit of a depression and
the worst thing about that type of
depression is nobody wants to hear you
talk about it there's no no tears shed
yes no sympathy whatsoever like oh
boohoo poor author sold three million
books or whatever
so it really caught me off guard and
and there was a little bit
you know there was imposter syndrome
which I think comes with any sort of
monumental success there was a little
bit of what do I do now
like how do I follow this up a lot of
insecurity of am I ever going to do
anything this meaningful or noteworthy
again
and I struggled with that for a number
of years and
that was just kind of on the emotional
and personal side that doesn't even get
into like relationships and
money I I feel like it's almost like
a
prerequisite
to being quote unquote wealthy is you
have to spend money on something stupid
that you regret like I just feel like
that is a non-negotiable you're not
really wealthy until you've done that at
some point so I went through a couple of
those experiences what would be the most
notable [ __ ] house
you know the the funny thing about me is
I I'm very I'm very minimalist I'm very
Spartan I don't really
like to have a lot of possessions but
for some reason when it was time to buy
a house I'm like you know what let's
just get all the rooms you know I've I
have nothing to put in them but let's
get them all
and that was just an unbelievable
mistake that that
really made my life a headache for a
while so
what are some of the things and just so
people listening understand where I'm
probably going with this there is a
there is a Meandering path but there is
a path is I want to talk about the
present tense and then I'm going to
rewind and do a I won't I don't want to
call it a Life review but look at some
of the trajectory at least insofar as
I've been able to
observe it in the course of watching you
do what you've done
from the from the sidelines but also
having done research for the
conversation so present tense though
building on what we're just talking
about what are some of the things you
thought you wanted
or needed that you got and you're like
huh
hmm
I would say actually the biggest thing
and this is kind of a broad thing but
I I think you and I are very similar in
that we started as online blog guys and
I think when you come up in the internet
world even if you amass a very large
audience at least for me there was
always a little bit of this chip on my
shoulder of like
I'm not a real writer like I don't I my
art I don't have an article in a
magazine I haven't there's hasn't been a
profile on me in a newspaper
and there seemed to be kind of like an
invisible wall between me and that world
and so for a number of years I
I really really wanted that for lack of
a better term mainstream media attention
just kind of like that nod of respect of
like yeah kid you did it and
when I started getting that and started
working and engaging with a lot of
Legacy Media
I was like wow this sucks
I miss my blog I miss I miss getting I
miss the emails from my readers like I
don't want to do this this is this is
such a pain yes we have like Zoom calls
with 11 people on them and I don't know
who half the people are that's been a
pretty eye-opening thing in the last few
years
[Music]
and to flesh out the current state
most people this thing will have heard
about Universal Pictures who have some
passing familiarity oh maybe I saw that
at the beginning of a movie I think yes
you did
not not a small entity and
I would love to know how this feature
film came to be
how did it come together and related to
that what does your current team look
like not only including any full-time
employees but also agents managers
Etc just what is that constellation look
like
the film I kind of Forrest Gump my way
into
after the book blew up a bunch of
Studios started sending offers to my
agent for sure to your book agent yes to
my book agent and I know you know this
but for everybody else it's it it's
pretty common for film and TV studios to
buy up rights to best-selling books
without any intention of actually doing
anything with them it's kind of just
like a land grab just in case you know
so and so director one day is like I
love that book I want to do a thing with
it
they already own it
so
out of all these offers that came
through you know
there was some pretty Off the Wall stuff
there was some stuff that I
couldn't ever imagine myself doing and I
told my agent I said you know if we do
any of these deals it's really important
like the only reason I think I'm ever
going to do a film or a TV show is to
Simply spread these same ideas to people
who don't read books like to me that's
the only reason to do this
so when they offer for a documentary
came through
from a production company that
specializes in documentaries and has
done a bunch of them based on books
before
to me it just seemed like a very logical
fit
I was like okay if I was to ever have a
movie that is the kind of project that I
would do I would feel good about
my agent told me she said these things
never get made don't get your hopes up I
was like okay cool I don't really
I've never had any ambition to have a
movie or be in the movies so I was like
cool kind of forgot about it
like a year and a half goes by and I get
a phone call
and it's the production company and
they're like guess what we got financed
by Universal and I was like okay what
does that mean and they're like
you're gonna have a movie you idiot do
you want to be at it you know and I was
like sure why not
and then from there you know next thing
I know I'm on a plane I'm flying down to
New Zealand I'm meeting with the
production company I'm meeting with
directors was New Zealand due to covid
is that why I was in New Zealand yes it
was so originally we were going to do it
the production company was is actually
based in New Zealand but we're
originally going to do it in New York
but then when covet happened I used it
also as an opportunity to just get the
hell away from covid so during this
whole process they're telling me we're
gonna have a theatrical release we're
gonna take it to festivals we're gonna
do this we're gonna do that and I I
don't know like I
maybe we and I'm sure we're going to
talk about will later but maybe from
being around will I just kind of became
jaded of like Hollywood people I I was
just like yeah sure while not really
believing it and yeah
sure enough we're a month out and it's
coming out it's gonna have a limited
theatrical release it's going to be
available online
and I seem to be the one who's like
wait this is actually happening it's one
of those projects that I can't take a
ton of credit for consciously like
navigating myself into like I don't have
like you know the three bullet points of
like how to get your movie made
I wish I did but step one of a
unexpected Global bestseller
step one step two books wait for a lot
of inbound
[Laughter]
yeah not very reproducible in terms of
your question about team
so I have my agent at CAA
and she's phenomenal she's amazing and
the amazing thing about her being at CAA
is that
it opens up all these crossover
opportunities
into film into TV it's how I I ended up
doing Will's book or a big part of why I
ended up doing Will's book
so she's great
I have my web team which is for
full-time people
I have a researcher I have a
content guy
that is his official title content guy
because it's just he just wears a lot of
hats and he kind of makes everything run
I have a tech developer Tech slash
development guy and then I have a social
media manager
it's all in-house everything we do is
in-house all the design
detect stuff the promotion the marketing
everything
we use a few Freelancers if we're doing
like video content stuff like that but
yeah that's the team right now number of
follow-up questions on this
the web team you said four full-time
people yeah now is that including the
researcher content guy
Tech and social or is that in addition
to so you end up having
seven or eight full-time folks no those
are the four positions
got it got it what does the researcher
do I mean I know they do research but
what type of research I don't have a
graduate degree in Psychology yet I
consistently find myself in the sticky
situation of
having to say something that feels
somewhat authoritative I mean I'm sure
you're in this position a lot too yes
yes so so at a certain point I just went
out and hired people with graduate
degrees in Psychology and said look like
can you just make sure I'm not putting
my foot in my mouth or giving terrible
advice so a lot of times I'll go to her
and I'll say
you know I've been thinking about an
article on
say the negative side effects of
self-esteem can you go out there like
find all the research and data what are
the studies are they good studies were
they done well
[Music]
and then just summarize it for me and
then you know if I want to dig into it
with her I can
she's been invaluable it's like she's
it's almost like Outsourcing a piece of
my brain somebody it's been very helpful
and I'm asking about the team
out of personal curiosity of course but
also because I enjoy and benefit from
hearing how people think about teams for
instance I'll give you an example
Kevin Kelly
arguably the most interesting man in the
world people should look him up kk.org
also the author of a famous article
called 1 000 true fans which I encourage
everybody to read
and he said to me once
explained to me rather that he has he
has an assistant and then he has a
researcher but they are not the same
person and he said in his experience
very often to optimize for one or the
other
you will find that they are somewhat
mutually exclusive in in other words the
the traits are somewhat mutually
exclusive now I don't know if I agree or
disagree with that but it was
an interesting observation based on the
pattern recognition from someone I
respect right
so the how did you choose full-time
versus
contractor or internal versus external
will be another way to put it I suppose
some of this is personal preference I
like working long term with people I
like finding
exceptional Talent
paying them very well and then sticking
with them over a long period of time so
I've never had an employee leave
[Music]
um
and two of two of my guys one's been
with me for 10 years one's been with me
for almost nine
and then the other two have been with me
for about three or four
which in in the web world is crazy
that's like crazy talk yeah it's an
eternity I have entrepreneur friends
with online businesses and they're they
look at me and they're like
are you nuts you like you could pay
these people half as much I'm like yeah
but I'd be hiring you know every six
months it'd be a fasting bar again yeah
you'd be you'd be paying for it with
your time exactly and I also just you
know there's something to be said with
the trust and loyalty like I don't know
how you measure that but there's the
trust and loyalty that comes with
working with somebody for 10 years you
know so we just
were two days before we're recording
this
we completely redesigned my site and
relaunched my newsletter it was a
multi-month project and
I know
like the guys that I have I know I don't
have to look over the shoulder yeah I
know they're going to get it done I know
it's going to be well done
and a lot of that is simply because
I've been with them for so long and
they've been with me for so long yeah
I feel the same way which is why I have
full-time team in addition to
contractors I do use Freelancers and
contractors how did you find
the members of your team and we don't
necessarily have to go one by one but do
you have a particular approach to
sourcing Talent
yes
so I've always always find them through
my email list and my subscribers
I've tried through kind of conventional
job searching venues and I just
you you get so much extra leverage from
I guess the fan relationship
generally every time I ask for
applications through my own audience
the people who apply are almost
comically overqualified and the talent
level is is through the roof and a lot
of that is just
they love my work they've been reading
it for years
and that that earns you a lot of
a lot of clout you know it does that
makes that makes sense and do you
mail out a link to a page with a job
description you just simply put it at
the end of one of your newsletters
you're like hey by the way I'm looking
for this is it dedicated how do you do
it
I will create a temporary page for the
position
I usually go through three steps
so I have the initial application it you
know ask for the generic stuff resume
cover letter I'll I'll usually ask a few
cute questions in there you know what
are your three favorite books
what was the last
risk that you took major risk you took
in your life and what happened things
like that although I'm discuss you know
as the years have gone on I'm
discovering that those questions aren't
really great filters
so I'll do that you know that's kind of
the first round I'll get hundreds and
hundreds of applications and then
I narrow it down to say 20 to 30 people
do you review all of those yourself
so sometimes I will have
a team member kind of go through and
just be like pick the highlights yeah or
anything that doesn't because I'll set
standards on the application page you
know so I'll tell them like anything
that doesn't meet the application
standards like just kick out so this
most recent round of higher I'm hiring a
video team to start doing more video
content and I asked for at least three
years of professional full-time
experience and
in some form of you know whether it's TV
film YouTube whatever
and sure enough you know you get 200
applications from people who have never
held a camera before but you know
they're they're really ready to learn
they can't wait to learn
it's nice to have somebody to kind of
just go and Mark those all red for me I
want a scholarship ride to graduate
school at Manson University exactly
exactly so I'll filter those down to 20
to 30 strong candidates people who meet
the requirements and seem smart and
talented and driven
and then I'll I'll actually give them
a few small pieces of work to do like
example tasks similar to what the
position is hiring for
and I'll give them a deadline to meet it
at and it's always funny because there's
always at least two or three people who
immediately complain about this and they
say you know you
this is slave labor you're taking
advantage of us you know you're using us
the crowdsource ideas for yourself which
is
silly because
I mean I understand why they think that
but I think anybody who is in our
industry understands that ideas aren't
the thing that matter
yeah and so
you know from that I'll narrow it down
to three to five people and then those
people I'll do
face-to-face Zoom interviews until I I
find the one that
feels like the right fit
what are you looking for in the
interviews by the time they get to the
interview they've basically shown that
they are completely qualified to do the
work they're probably going to do a
great job
the interviews for me it's
99 looking for intangibles looking for
personality character
I usually try to get a sense of what
their values are
get a sense of how resilient they are
how
do they take responsibility for
themselves a little bit about their
background things like that but also
just like do I get along with them do I
like talking to them
do we have a sense of humor that meshes
well
things like that
makes sense last question on the team
and there's a point to all these people
listening part of which is just
satisfying my own interests big big part
of which but
CAA this agent there are a lot of agents
and you've got quite a few three-letter
acronyms to choose from right you've got
CAA WME UTA and there are many other
Boutique agencies and so on
a lot of people out there who could
ostensibly probably do a pretty good job
many who would promise the moon and do a
terrible job
but how specifically did you
decide on this this agent that you work
with at CAA
so my blog blew up in 2014. 2013 2014 it
kind of went from maybe a hundred
thousand readers to
million million and a half
and
around that time agents and Publishers
started coming knocking asking if I
wanted to turn some of my work into a
book and so I had a number and at that
time again you know homegrown internet
guy I self-published my first book I
I've been selling online courses since
2010
I've always
I've always had a little bit of an
irrational like I want to do it myself
mentality but back then I had a very
very irrational I want to do it myself
mentality so a lot of my calls with
these editors and agents was basically
me just being a bit of a dick and being
like why why should I publish a book at
all why shouldn't I just self-publish I
get way more royalties or whatever and
it was funny because
pretty much everybody in the publishing
industry kind of stumbled over that
question they couldn't really give me a
satisfying answer
so my agent her name's Molly
at the time she wasn't at CAA she was at
a small boutique agency in New York
so I get on the phone with her and we
start having a conversation and she's
constantly interrupting me she's
constantly talking over me
she's very aggressive and assertive
to the point that I I'm getting a little
bit uncomfortable talking to her and so
I I throw out my gotcha question you
know like
why should I even publish a book at all
you know I could self-publish a book and
keep all the royalties for myself
and she kind of sat there silently and
she was like
well figure out what the hell you want
to do stop wasting my time call me if
you want to publish a book and like hung
up on me and I was like God damn all
right and a couple hours go by and I
start thinking to myself I'm like
that's who I want bargaining on my
behalf you know if I have a six or seven
figure negotiation with somebody like I
want her on my team so I called her back
and I said I'm in
and she's a total rock star in her field
and it was again Forrest Gump moment so
right around right before subtle art
came out she called me and she said hey
I just want to let you know I'm moving
to a new agency Nothing's Gonna Change
going over to CAA and I was like oh cool
what's CAA and she was like you know
kind of like thought I was joking I
guess she didn't answer me and I
remember like I I Googled CAA and if you
go to their website it just has like a a
snail mail address there's like
literally nothing on the website there's
nothing so for folks wondering if they
don't know it's creative artists agency
it's one of the largest I suppose we
could call it talent agencies in the
world they represent a lot of the
everybody top tier
a grade celebrities you would recognize
yeah and it was maybe a week later I was
talking to my editor and he was he's he
goes hey congrats and I was like for
what and he goes Molly Molly moving the
CAA I was like yeah why are you telling
me congrats and he just looked at me
like I was the biggest [ __ ] idiot
like he's like he's like Manson you just
won the lottery
speaking of winning the lottery let's
let's talk about this is going to be a
bit of a strained metaphor but
putting yourself in a position where at
least you have a chance at winning the
lottery
and I'm gonna I'm gonna further confuse
Matters by reading a paragraph from a
Wikipedia entry on a video game and this
will hopefully make some sense for
people in a second
there's a video game called and I don't
know how it's pronounced in English
actually but Katamari damasi in English
but it's in Japanese it's Katamari
damashi which
literally means Clump Spirit and the
reason I learned about this video game
was in a presentation by Matt cutts who
at the time
was at Google and he was giving a
presentation I think it was at the state
of the word or an annual WordPress
Meetup I could be getting those
specifics wrong but I was there
and he described how he observed people
building audiences over time
this is where we're gonna
go through the Looking Glass and go back
in time with your story but here's
here's the plot this is directly from
Wikipedia the games plot concerns a
diminutive Prince I'm not saying you're
a dominative prince but the games plot
concerns a diminutive Prince on a
mission to rebuild the stars
constellation and moon which were
inadvertently destroyed by his father
the king of all Cosmos this is achieved
by Rolling a magical highly adhesive
ball called a Katamari around various
locations collecting increasingly larger
objects this is the key part ranging
from thumbtacks to human beings to
mountains until the ball has grown large
enough to become a star it goes on and
on so that's Katamari damashi at least
in Japanese I suspect they changed the
spelling d-a-m-a-c-y is the trademark it
but that's a side note all right Matt's
point was
when you first start
you are generally in these success
stories he has seen starting very small
with a ball that's rolling up thumbtacks
and then eventually it gets a little bit
bigger and you move to larger objects
and then you get to humans and you get
to mountains and so on
and I thought maybe we could start if
you're open to it with you telling the
backstory
on a character maybe not a character a
person named entropy
could you explain who entropy is or was
and then walk us through the development
because it seems to parallel this video
game in actually very similar way that
my trajectory has mirrored this video
game in a sense the metaphor at least so
entropy who is entropy oh god well it
ironically enough it was originally my
gaming handle when I was in high school
but it was my I guess you call it a
pseudonym of my first blog
I started blogging my roommate had a
Blog in college
and he and I
the the pickup artist thing was popular
at the time and so there was a lot of
kind of writing story like oh I went on
a date last weekend this is what
happened and
my him and another friend of mine were
kind of always egging me to
start a blog dude start a blog and it
was really just because
you know we all read each other's
stories and stuff and they wanted to
read mine
so
that's actually how it first started was
just me my my roommate like peer
pressuring me into sharing stupid drunk
things I did and what year is this
roughly
this is 2007 2007. okay I was 23 and
doing things that 23 year olds do
and there was there was really no
again Forrest gumping my way into it
right like there's no ambition or
at that stage there was no ambition or
kind of vision for this like it's just
the cool thing that my friends want me
to do
and I I enjoyed it too I found that was
kind of actually the first point in my
life that I discovered like hey it's
really fun to sit down and write
something
just because you enjoy it not because
it's a term paper or whatever
so that went on for about a year and I
don't think you know the quote unquote
readership was probably never more than
a dozen people
but then something strange started
happening which is people that I had
never met
started reading it and commenting on it
and I have no idea how these people
found me or where they came from
and
that was a little bit mind-blowing to me
and it was around that time I started to
get very curious this also coincides I
was just out of school the Great
Recession was going on so there were no
jobs at anywhere I was basically living
on a friend's couch
in
it kind of opened up this idea of like
hey there's internet stuff you can do
like you can this blogging thing is that
actually a thing you can promote
products and get commissions you can put
ads on your on your site like you can
make a little bit of chump change
if you think about it and are strategic
about it
and this is so this story is going to
lead to you Tim I gotta I gotta warn you
so I started getting curious about I
guess you would call like kind of the
online marketing online blogging world
and
it was around that time I discovered
four hour work week I think it had just
come out or been out for like a year or
something yeah that was April 2007 it
came out seems like a lifetime ago yeah
so I found that and I read it so to your
credit I read that book and it blew
opened my mind in terms of like what the
possibilities were I was just like oh my
God you could do all sorts of [ __ ]
online and you know automate this stuff
and oh my God I would be living in
Argentina and this is gonna be great
like I'm like sign me up dude like Let
Me Argentina here I come exactly so I
had a very love-hate experience with
that book but in hindsight both were
good so the love side of it was
it just opened my mind to so many
possibilities the hate side of it was
I I thought it was going to be so much
easier I thought you know like the way
the way you describe some of those
examples I'm like oh yeah this was like
a month tops like you know meanwhile a
year and a half later I'm still grinding
like 12 hours a day so you know I went
through a period of like God damn that
Tim Ferriss like what the hell was I
thinking you and I have had a
complicated relationship you're not
aware of most of it but oh tell me
no no I mean it was a difficult but very
very rewarding
period in terms of just trying all these
different websites and blogs and
SEO pages and AdSense pages and 90 of it
doesn't work and then the 10 that works
like
you're making it brings in a hundred
bucks a month and you're like okay well
if I can just do 10 more of those
maybe that gets me somewhere and so it
was one of those grinds that you look
back with like some Nostalgia and like
you know there's a little bit of romance
to it like I would never I don't think
I'd ever be able to stomach it today but
as a broke 25 year old I'm really proud
of it and what was the website or the
primary websites at the time oh man so
back then Google was rewarding blogs and
the idea was you build up a Blog you
create a bunch of articles about
whatever the topic is you get a little
bit of traffic and then you either put
ads or do like affiliate links so I had
uh I had a Blog for like
feng shui I had a Blog for teeth
whitening strategies I had a Blog for
oh God I'm trying to remember oh like
bartending like Mixology and bartending
keep in mind like half the stuff I
didn't actually know anything about I
just Googled other stuff and rewrote it
not the greatest work I've ever done but
in a way it was putting in the hours and
meanwhile I had the entropy blog which
was still writing about my dating life
and
ironically I guess I had to learn this
the hard way that was the thing that
actually caught traction because it was
the thing that I actually cared about
and I actually thought about a lot from
my day-to-day and probably also enjoyed
writing about more so than teeth
whitening and feng shui yeah yeah 100
times more not to knock either one of
those
gonna get a lot of dentist hate mail
coming to you I don't want to miff the
teeth whitening young adults novel
writers out there yeah right
so that's what started to take off and
I kind of found myself you know I in
college I dabbled in the pickup artist
stuff and
my blog as my blog started to get
accepted in those circles
guys started asking me to coach them
they wanted to do calls they wanted to
meet up with me you know they wanted to
bring me down to New York and go out the
bars with me and
as a guy with nothing else going on that
was really enticing it was really
exciting and so I kind of got sucked
into that world for about I'd say a year
year and a half
and
and then was
pretty strongly turned off by it it felt
very obviously there was a lot of toxic
advice in that industry but also just
the the Dynamics
of everything was so performative you
know like it nobody actually really
cared if you were having a good time or
not nobody cared if the woman you met
was really smart or interesting or funny
you know it was just like did you make
out with her did you get her phone
number no all right you're you're not on
the scoreboard tonight you know like
that was that was kind of the extent of
their thinking and so
I started to become pretty grossed out
by it but also at the same time I
realized that there was very much an
opportunity to
to integrate some of those more healthy
emotional elements into it so
I rebranded my website my blog my little
blog as practical pickup
I started using my real name I started
promoting
honesty vulnerability
actually giving a [ __ ] about who you're
talking to instead of just trying to
like press the right buttons to to get
her into bed and yeah I guess you would
say that was another like that's when
that ball started picking up yeah bigger
and bigger items started broadening the
scope let me ask you you know this just
popped in my head and I'll give a
confession first so if I go back and
look at the oldest versions of my blog
over time
they're awful right like some of them
are really really hard on the eyes and
that that is not what I'm gonna say
about my question coming right now but
I'm curious am I making this up that on
one of your blogs in the early days
there's a photo of you with like a very
low-cut v-neck shirt on it am I making
that up it just popped into my head is
that a real thing I had like a goofy
picture of me with like a scarf and
sunglasses
it was Tim you're bringing out like this
is this is the douchey 25 year old Mario
I'm not
I want to clarify my intentions here
okay okay my intention is to show how
this ball Works in practice to use the
video game analogy in the same way that
I started with very narrow at least in
the blog
capacity I started very narrow Tech
audience focused
productivity slot that's where I focused
and really I was speaking
almost directly to people in Silicon
Valley where I lived at the time it was
very very narrow and then it expanded
and after the success of the first book
realized I didn't want to get painted
into the corner of being the X Hour Work
Week guy forever but I had the
optionality at that point which might
not come again to try something totally
different because I knew
Publishers would take the Gamble just
based on the audience that I built so I
did for our body and then it started to
expand from there and I want to
perhaps provide a little bit of
historical context also for the time
that we're discussing right they're in
2005
I want to say the game by Neil Strauss
came out some somewhere around there and
then I want to say it was in that same
range 2005 2006 that I hope they serve
beer and Hell came out by Tucker Max
and no matter what people feel about the
content in those books and the subject
matter covered
both of those got a lot of young men or
let's say boys on the verge of becoming
men's late adolescents both yeah writing
for the first time yeah and then both
authors you know tiger Max and Neil
Strauss ended up doing their own version
of rolling this ball afterwards right
and so my my intention here is to point
out
in a sense how much went into
contributing to where you are today not
saying you would replicate it if you
attempted to in the same way but that's
that's why I'm going through this
backstory because also and I'm sort of
showing the punchline in a sense and I'd
be interested to know if you
think this is a fair comment
a lot of folks especially I think right
now when they're able to study
or at least see supposed case studies of
people becoming these overnight
successes on platforms like Tick Tock
and so on they dramatically overestimate
what they are capable of doing in three
months but they dramatically
underestimate what they would be capable
of doing in three years let's say yeah
and that's why we're having this
conversation in part because a lot of
folks are like oh Mark Manson that's the
subtle art of not giving a [ __ ] guy oh
my God huge mega bestseller I'm so glad
that he did that and what a genius and
you may very well be a genius but I want
to provide the backstory to the genius
if that makes sense for sure and it is
there's 10 years of quiet iteration
behind that that big breakthrough
success right and so going from you know
100 a month with teeth whitening and
feng shui to writing a book with Will
Smith like that is it's a dramatic
transition but it's not a one-step phase
shift right it's this sort of
incremental build and that's that's the
picture that I'm trying to paint so when
did you go from then the sort of
pick up expanded into honesty
vulnerability and then bleeding into
relationships to broader advice
so the transitions
happened
the pickup stuff kind of started 2009
I'd say
the honesty vulnerability stuff the next
year 2010
what and then what I realized I think in
2012
either late 2012 early 2013 something
really strange happened which is I
realized that like 25 30 of my audience
was female
bizarre because I'm explicitly writing
men's dating advice and it is written in
a way that it's like dudes in a locker
room talking to each other
but a lot of I kept getting emails from
women saying you know I don't relate to
this or that but this advice you gave
about boundaries is the best thing I've
ever heard it's better than any female
advice that I've ever seen
I started getting an email after email
of that so it it occurred to me that it
no longer made sense to limit myself to
simply writing writing for men and so I
took that step the further step of just
rebranding to just my name
I'm gonna write about
for everybody and initially it was
mostly dating relationship advice but
the other kind of
thing I started to notice around that
time as well
by then I had been writing dating and
relationship stuff for like five years
and
when you really dig down into it
there's no such thing as a dating
problem like every dating problem is
simply a personal emotional
slash trauma slash baggage problem for
sure that is manifesting as a dating
problem human problem it's just the
human problem so I was like you know I I
don't really think it's valuable for me
to sit here and you know write things
like top five first date locations you
know whatever I should be talking about
this deeper level stuff because that is
what everybody seems to be struggling
with so that was also part of the
transition of getting into I guess what
you would call more traditional personal
development topics
if we then Flash Forward so we have this
like Blurry Austin Powers kind of
transition and we end up I believe tell
me if I'm getting this right January 8th
2015. hmm I may be getting this right
blog post
2354 words I believe
so this is this is the big one this is
the motherlood and my question is
before the blog post became the subtle
art of not giving a [ __ ] what other
names did you consider for that if you
even remember
and or how did you just end up with
title because
I you think a lot about word smithing
and and crafting and I know you spent
time on this and I know you have spent a
lot of time thinking about
headlines and titles so
what was the process of getting to that
so just there's not really a way to
answer that without kind of going back a
little bit and talking about
what that era of social media was and
what kind of my whole process was back
then great
I think I had my first like Mega viral
Post in 2012 early 2013 and
what I don't think it took a while for
everybody to figure out but it was right
around then that Facebook
turned on the spigot of reach for
outside published material like Facebook
kind of decided that they wanted to be
the newspaper for everybody
and so if you were able to write
an attention-grabbing headline
you know a little bit of copy have a
intriguing image
you would just go crazy on that platform
and so
the big growth spurt that happened in my
audience was on Facebook from 2013 to
2015 subtle art was actually one of the
last
viral articles I had in a series of
probably eight or ten by our very viral
articles over that two-year period
I kind of discovered this and then
started refining a process and as you
pointed out like a huge part of the
process was title I just realized like
the title is almost as important as the
entire article itself so I started
spending hours just writing out
dozens and dozens of titles
and I also just kept around title ideas
that I had
you know I just had a Google doc that
I'd be out at dinner with a friend and
he'd make a joke and I'm like ah that'd
be a really good article title and I'd
like pull out my phone and jot it down
on the Google Docs so
the subtle art the title had been
sitting on that Google doc for a while
so I'm a big metal fan
and the
the band Lamb of God has a song called
the subtle art of murder and persuasion
and it was right around that time I
forget I had a couple articles with
another thing about Facebook's algorithm
at the time I noticed that if I just put
[ __ ] in the title
you know you would get like 50 more
juice turbo boost yeah exactly it was
like a cheat code for Facebook my mind
was already in a spot where I'm like
looking back in the wholesome good old
days
oh my God
so you know my mind I was already kind
of existing in a headspace where I'm
always on the lookout for like a clever
use of the f word and and so I was
listening I was huge fan of Lamb of God
and that song comes on on my my iPhone
or whatever the subtle art of murder
persuasion and I was like the subtle art
of not giving a [ __ ] I was like wow
that's that's really catchy
and then it sat on the document for a
while and then it's actually funny kind
of how the article got written
it sat there for many months it never
really
I never really felt the inspiration to
do something with it and then there was
a period
that holiday the Christmas and New
Year's right before that that like as
you said it came out January 8th that
holiday was really shitty for a variety
of personal reasons
it was just one of those Christmas
holidays that you're like [ __ ] why do I
have a family
and
like do I have to spend time with these
people so
you know I was coming out of that in a
pretty bummed out State yeah my wife who
I was not engaged to yet at the time
there was like Visa trouble so she was
you know stuck in Brazil so I'm like
basically I was actually in Austin I was
sitting alone like basically just moping
in Austin for a few weeks and when I get
mopey I get very very snarky and like
like bitingly sarcastic and so
it was time to write an article and I
pull up the list and I see that title
and I'm like you know what I'm going to
write the most offensive
profane thing I can possibly imagine but
I'm also going to
give the best possible advice that I
I imagine I can give I'm going to
combine the two things and I just want
to create that like dissonance in people
and so I wrote it and I thought it was
completely over the top and ridiculous
and you know sometimes when you write
something
I'm sure you have this experience like
you're you can't really tell if it's
good or not like yeah you're too close
to it yeah so I put it away I woke up
the next day I was still unsure about it
and I sent it to my content guy official
title
and I told him who also kind of acts as
an editor for me and I told him I was
like I don't even know if I want to post
this it's pretty ridiculous and he came
back on slack in like all caps and he
was like you can fire me I'm posting
this [ __ ] thing he's like this is the
best thing we have to post this
and sure enough he was right like it
just it went absolutely crazy
it was everywhere
yeah I remember that I do remember that
the the banner with the kitten and all
that I remember seeing that when it came
out and I was like that's really really
good headline it was a good piece too I
but I remember thinking man
every once in a while you know it could
be an album it could be and this this
Harkens back to my early days when I had
the Sports Nutrition Company and it was
doing now what would be called D to C
but lots of paid advertising so I needed
headlines to work so I was also working
with very expensive long lead
Publications like magazines good Lord
you think it's
hard to Zig and zag online man with that
type of lag time it's brutal so I
developed a
an affection for really really good
titles and headlines and I was like man
that that's a gold medal right there and
out of curiosity of the eight or so
articles that you had go Mega viral in a
two-year period
which especially in the context of that
time is a very high hit rate I mean
thinking back to that time I was on the
playing field that's a very high hit
rate how many of those
started with a headline and then became
an article because I would imagine most
people who write
write something and then try to come up
with the headline oftentimes I think
that will be the case
I would say half there's probably 50 50.
what was second place in terms of
virality Do You Remember
second place was seven strange questions
that help you find your life purpose
and then the number one question was
what is your favorite flavor of [ __ ]
sandwich and does it have an olive
[Laughter]
oh the questions the questions so things
go completely cuckoo bananas
and watching it from
I suppose I was saying the sidelines but
kind of front row seats because I was
tracking
things in in the blogosphere roughly
speaking quite closely because I was
still so involved we're in the same
space we have mutual friends you know so
oh yeah it would make sense how many
blog posts have you written
do you have any idea
well the site still houses about 250 but
yeah a lot of them have been
removed or decommissioned decommissioned
you know thank you for your service
you're no longer necessary
I I would say probably in the
neighborhood of five six hundred yeah I
mean that's solid Cannon yeah and after
let's see a thousand plus on my blog
because I got started in 2005 so I had a
bit more of a lead time
ended up spending a lot of time thinking
about crafting of of certainly pieces
and also
headlines let's
before we delve into sort of the
the explosion after that event and I
think a lot of people might be able to
fill in some of the gaps because they
they I would imagine at least more than
a handful of folks will have some
familiarity with maybe the later
chapters of what the success of that
book looks like and seeing the orange
cover everywhere any airport anywhere in
the world there it is I actually do want
to ask about the cover because that's
I think
an element that has also worked
tremendously well yeah but before we get
to that what are the things that you
most struggle with
now
or recently
so this is going to be a bit of a blase
answer
especially probably for you and your
audience I have always struggled with
the physical health side of things
I spent pretty much all of my 20s kind
of getting my head
you know in order getting my baggage
cleaned out
fixing my relationships understanding my
emotions developing self-awareness all
these things you know I was always so
focused on that
that I never really developed good
habits around taking care of myself
and so it's I'm at that point now in my
late 30s where you actually pay for
those bad habits you know because when
you're 28
you don't really pay for it yeah I hit a
point a year or two ago where I realized
it's never going to get easier or better
so it's not a sexy answer it's kind of a
blah answer but it's you know the last
year especially has been very very
health focused I've actually been
listening to a shitload of your episodes
on subjects like that appreciate that
it's been very helpful
you have a health piece you know this is
I'm 45 now and
all of those little decisions add up and
I've I've been pretty good at
maintenance but I've also just through
Pure Life aggression sustained
30 plus fractures handful of surgeries
and holy [ __ ] do those add up do those
start to reappear and the degree of
self-care
what I've realized just needs to go up
in a very non-linear fashion the older
you get or you just start sliding in a
really significant way so
I'm in a maybe a similar boat in the
sense that I'm also in the last year and
certainly for this upcoming year going
to be focusing on the health component
because it's this
Upstream variable that just affects
positively or negatively everything else
so yeah for what it's worth I'm happy to
chat about that anytime thanks Ben I
appreciate that you know whatever I feel
like I'm getting off the rails it's just
for what it's worth I have found and I
have some degenerative disc issues in my
back also which is unfortunate but
congenital
kettlebell swings slow carb diet perhaps
also skipping one or two meals let's
just say breakfast because I find that
easier than portion control yeah and
some type of core work whether it's
something like Pilates or really
technical Pilates or
let's just say gymnastics strength
training also but that's a bit more
aggressive on the joints so you have to
have that
stability slash connective tissue
strength but if I just do core work
kettlebell swings
push-ups
and
some type of diet that restricts
High caloric density carbohydrates to
some extent
um
it really makes a huge difference what
do you have pains do you have a lot of
pains
in terms of symptoms is that I actually
don't
I'm very fortunate in that regard I just
got fat
I mean especially we're going to get to
my run the last five years and all the
projects I did you know I I overworked I
over did it yeah the wake-up call for me
was actually I was
I was writing three books at the same
time
sorry yeah yeah I know you for you no
you know like how stupid that is I was
writing three books at the same time
living in New York I'm traveling I'm on
planes like if not every week every
other week and I was actually sitting in
my office one morning and I started
having intense heart pain and or chest
pain I should say I started having
intense chest pain and it freaked me out
you know I have a history of heart
disease in my family and I was like
[ __ ] 37 like this can't be happening
so you know sat down went to a doctor
ran all the tests everything's fine
but he looked at me he's like have you
had any stress going on in your work
lately
but yeah I had gained you know I had
gained probably 25 30 pounds the little
exercise I had been doing before then I
you know went out the window my eating
habits were terrible my sleeping habits
were terrible I had massive circles
under my eyes
and I I kind of had just this come to
Jesus moment of like dude you can't put
this off any longer you have to do
something to take care of it and it
there was also a little bit of a
a humbling that had to happen
of realizing that after a number of
years of trying to do it myself that I
just for whatever reason like this part
of my life I don't seem to have good
decision control
so I hired a coach and that was super
helpful
and it's it's you know speaking of that
kind of Snowball Effect the more the
further I go down the path the more I
want to go down the path and I also feel
a little bit stupid because
my whole thing for 15 years now has all
has been all about
how people think and feel and helping
them you know deal with struggles and
pain in their life better and I'm
sitting here and I'm like wow not
drinking for a few weeks going to bed at
like 10 p.m I feel 20 better on a
day-to-day basis how did I not realize
this before like how am I so late to
this party it's been an interesting
experience just out of curiosity where
were you when you stopped drinking and
started going to bed earlier getting a
solid night's sleep just geographically
where were you L.A L.A I asked because
New York in my experience I grew up on
Long Island I've spent a ton of time in
New York City
it is just a cultural norm
to
I mean to drink four or five nights a
week and you get on this caffeine
booze seesaw and which is the norm for
millions of people yep every week if not
every day and I just that's why I was
asking about the switch
I was completely unprepared for how
influential moving from New York to LA
would be in in that in that factory
because you were absolutely right all
social life New York revolves around
eating and drinking alcohol and
yeah after seven years
it adds up like it really adds up
whereas in La like
you know people don't drink nearly as
much everybody wants to go on a hike
they want to surf they want to like you
know
go hang out on the beach so it's it's
it's been very good yeah the wear of
Health matters a lot yeah not just the
how of Health I mean the how of health
is often a consequence of the wear in a
way right yeah la la does have that in
Spades if you haven't been to the
the Venice boardwalk green on I want to
say a Sunday when the acrobats go to
train you should definitely check that
out you see Cirque du Soleil athletes
practicing nice on this on this green
which is probably I don't know 30 by 30
feet and
if you just want a casual pass by a
Cirque du Soleil performance you can
take a look at that it's inspiring it's
really really inspiring so let's let's
talk about the five-year period of
projects
and three books at once oh my god
oh boy yeah that's a lot could you
describe what you did with Will Smith
how it came to be and your personal
primary Lessons Learned doesn't have to
be from the content of the book it could
also be from the interactions exposure
to La entertainment Etc just love to
know
what you did for people who don't know
yeah how it happened maybe those are in
the opposite order and then
what your personal
primary Lessons Learned work from that
so I co-authored Will Smith's Memoir
which came out last year it's called
will
we worked on it for about
I think about two and a half years
together
the way it came about was his team
actually reached out to me he had wanted
to do a book for a little while and
from what I understood I wasn't there
but from what I understand he had you
know some kind of casual meetings with a
few different authors
just to kind of see what was out there
and
when they contacted me about it
first of all another story of my agent
being great my agent didn't tell me
about it right away the first thing she
did is she sent me an email and she said
hypothetical question if a celebrity
wanted to write a book with you
on what terms would you be interested
which is smart because she didn't tell
me who it was yeah it's smart
and I said it would have to be an
a-lister
and they would have to want it to be
more than
just about their life like they would
want to like dig into their problems and
history and
baggage
Etc
which is as it so happens exactly what
will wanted to do
so
after that we set up the meeting
super surreal I don't know I always tell
people like
the craziest part
about meeting a really really famous
person isn't actually the really really
famous person it's all the [ __ ] that
goes on around the super famous person
it's hard to explain but next thing I
know I'm getting whisked away to
Atlanta where I'm supposed to meet him
on set
of a film that he's working on turns out
Ang Lee is working is directing that
film so I start like don't Fanboy at
angli don't Fanboy Will Smith like oh
God like this is so stressful and you're
supposed to just kind of act casual like
this is all normal so he he finishes
there like rehearsing a scene or
something and I'm like
I'm like walking in circles not knowing
where you're supposed to go and
because people are like are you okay and
I'm like where should I sit I've never
been on a Hollywood set before like what
do I do with my hands what do I do with
my hands like Ricky Bobby
I told one of his managers I was like
I've never been on a Hollywood set
before I don't know if I'm like in the
right place or not she just kind of
looked at me like really and I was like
sorry
you know so next thing I know they
finished rehearsing we go straight to an
airstrip getting loaded onto a private
jet and they're like no no you need to
sit in the front with will because
you're gonna talk about the book now and
I'm like now like this is okay you know
first time on a jet so the whole thing
is just surreal and strange and
everywhere he goes there's a mob of fans
waiting for him people shrieking
so it took a few days to kind of like
Get over that get in a room with him
privately where it's quiet and actually
have kind of an extended one-on-one
conversation with him and
before I went to meet him I had two
conditions for myself which was the
first one is he can't be an [ __ ]
because I just
nothing is no amount of money no matter
Prestige is worth spending three years
working with an [ __ ]
and then two was you know there needs to
be something legitimately like he
everything needs to be on the table he
needs to be very willing to open up and
kind of go anywhere so we had a few
really good productive conversations and
I was blown away the thing that
really knock my socks off about him
I mean he's a smart guy obviously he's a
very hard-working guy obviously
his charisma
in his ability to read a room and react
in a way that makes people feel
comfortable
and then also kind of talking to him a
little bit about some of the the hurdles
that he went through in his life his
ability to adapt to set back
to reframe it in a way that is helpful
to himself
it it it's really incredible like he
he's one of the and I know this seems
strange to say after the Oscars incident
but he really is one of the most
emotionally intelligent people that I've
been around
and so we had a dinner the last night
and he kind of just out of the blue was
like so what's up Mark we gonna do a
book or what and I was like well I've
got an outline in mind and I said
you know
I told him the thing I just said about
emotions and his ability to use his
emotions to adapt to things I also said
it's probably why he's such a good actor
is that it's
he's able to summon emotions and play
with them and react to them in a
masterful way
and I said so I think the book should be
built around emotion it starts with fear
it moves through all your defense
mechanisms into your Fame into all the
success until
that facade collapsing and it eventually
finally ends up at at love at a very
genuine authentic love which is kind of
something that it took him a long time
to get to
and I said in As you move through all
those emotions there's there's a word
for somebody who's able to move through
setbacks and and deal with any sort of
negative emotion and harness it
to Advantage them and I said it's it's
will so that should be the name of the
book
and it was like the Fresh Prince came
back like he was just like hell yeah he
like gets up starts like slamming stuff
on the table he's like hell yeah hell
yeah we doing that and I'm like all
right so I got the gig like
it was a good meeting good meeting yeah
good meeting good meeting
but it was a wild and fun two years with
him
he is honestly I mean as you can imagine
I get so many questions
since
March about him
but honestly he's
such a great guy deep down obviously he
makes mistakes and does stupid things
like the rest of us but
I have nothing but gratitude for that
project it was very easy to write it was
very enjoyable the way we did it was
I presented the outline we kind of
refined it together
I wrote the first draft
he did a revision of that and then me
and the editor at penguin kind of like
did a final pass
so it really is both of us in that book
like it's a lot of people assume it was
all me or assume it was all him I don't
know but like it really was both of us
like he put a lot of work and effort
into it and he really cared about it
so I'm going to ask about what you
learned about Hollywood and
entertainment through the process of
interacting with him and
writing the book
I'll just open a door if you want to
walk through it if not we could skip it
I know you just mentioned a lot of
people have asked you about the Oscars
and Chris Rock incident and so on is
there anything you want to say about
that or about him with respect to that
or not you can also just say nope not
really and we can move on totally up to
you so I I publicly wrote a piece about
it
as a newsletter it's on my website
the tldr of it is basically
yeah he did something really stupid and
unacceptable but as somebody who spent a
lot of time around him not just him his
family his friends
getting to know his kids getting to know
his brother
he is honestly there is so much
generosity that happens with him that
nobody ever sees and it's very much by
Design like he doesn't
he doesn't feel a need to publicize it
and so just seeing what I've seen being
around him
I kind of told people to like look
that's not the real him that's like the
worst side of him you know the will that
you know and that you hope is real is
that's the real will he's he's a very
great
loving but flawed human being
in terms of what I learned oh and you
asked earlier what I learned from him
it's funny because that project I didn't
you know he he does have a marvelous
story of resilience and overcoming I
mean he come he comes from a very
dysfunctional family an abusive father
grew up on the streets of West Philly
like very rough neighborhoods
and it's it's actually very remarkable
how he navigated that
avoided all the pitfalls that come with
that sort of upbringing to get where he
is today it's definitely not an accident
so that story is amazing but there was
nothing in it that really
you know there were no epiphanies for me
personally the epiphanies for me
personally were just being around him as
a professional you know being around a
guy like that who's been at the top of
his game top of his field for 30 years
one of the most famous human beings on
the planet
I was blown away at the way he
worked with his team
the way he was with his fans the way he
dealt with the media
I mean to be honest dude like I the
first time I hung out with him and I saw
him get mobbed by fans my immediate
reaction was like man I should be nicer
to my fans like I think will is nicer to
his fans than I am and like he's he is
he's Will Smith like he's paddling out
through 100 foot waves every time he
steps steps out of a door yeah but one
of the things that he he helped me see
and he he said this to me too is he said
you know he was like I'm very aware that
every encounter I have
with a fan is a very asymmetric
encounter like for me it's five seconds
that I'm gonna forget about
you know within a minute
for them it's five seconds they're gonna
remember for the rest of their lives so
he's like
just put in the effort for those five
seconds like it's not the payoff is so
Monumental for the other person that it
there's kind of no
ethical argument to not do it
the other thing that he said that was
really profound for me because as you
can imagine he's got this like full
staff of people that just follow him
around the world he's got cooks and
chefs and
wardrobe people and
Security Guys and everything Logistics
and I asked him once I was like do you
ever feel like it's kind of weird
just having this like
team of people that just Shadow you
everywhere you go quicker you know I was
like when was the last time you cooked a
meal for yourself and he like started
laughing and he's like I don't know man
probably at least 10 years
but he told me he said he's like look
it's really simple like I I am world
class at one thing
and
yeah it'd be very easy for me to like be
the humble guy and cook a meal for
myself and send the chef home
but
I'm only world class at one thing and
that would take away from my time and
energy from being world class at that
one thing and not only that but my chef
is world class at one thing
and by sending him home I am taking away
from his ability to be world class at
the thing that he's world class at
that's cool yeah I saw potentially the
first part coming but not the second
part yeah that's that's a significant
addition right looking through
the mirror from the other direction not
just your direction and he described it
as robbing him of an opportunity to be
excellent which I just to me it was like
such a beautiful
it's funny because you know you hear so
many Outsourcing conversations in terms
of business of like how to hire an
Outsource and do all this and automate
and do all this stuff he spoke about it
in ethical terms which
who was really profound for me yeah
what did You observe
or what stood out to you about how he
worked with his team
outside of that example they just gave
this kind of validates what we were
talking about earlier the first thing
that really stood out to me about his
team
was
they've all been with him forever
and it was funny I was talking to one
he's got one guy named Scotty who I love
he's Scotty's been in a few of his
YouTube videos lovely lovely guy
and Scotty was kind of joking with me
he's like yeah I'm the new guy on the
team I've only been here nine years
everybody in like significant roles in
his team have been with him since at
least the Fresh Prince days many of them
since
since the 80s some of them since he was
a kid
they're like childhood friends that he
kind of put into the appropriate place
so that that really blew me away it also
validated a lot of my beliefs around
loyalty and
Trust
he also explained it to me once as he
said he was like look when you become
famous
nothing is scarce like if you want money
you can go get money if you want parties
you can go get parties if you want sex
you can go get sex he said the one thing
that becomes more scarce as you become
famous is trust and so he said I very
much
tried to build my organization to
optimize for trust first and everything
else second
which I thought was very wise
of him but in terms of just
operationally like he's he he's very
good at including everybody like he's
very
you know there's no like rigid hierarchy
of like oh well you're
you're the assistant of this manager so
like you shouldn't be in the room
talking about these ideas he loves to
just joke and bounce creative ideas
around and if it's like the lowly
production assistant who comes back with
a with a great idea like
he's happy with that like he'll run with
it
he doesn't feel like a possessiveness
around like who gets to tell him what
hmm
fascinating
super super fascinating
what what are your goals
desires wants maybe I don't know how
crazy we want to get but in the next say
you can choose the time frame three
years right because there was a point as
you said you're writing for your friends
in college
readership per se of
no more than a dozen people not really
thinking about where this is going or
how you're going to optimize it it's
just writing having fun with friends and
enjoying the process
now you have
among other things Paradox of choice
situation on your hands where there's
more inbound than you can probably even
begin to process even more than your
agent can probably process she has to
have some quick means of eliminating
things yeah
how are you thinking about what you want
to do or not do over the next
handful of years
the place I'm in now I mean I will write
more books but I'm kind of in this like
almost like prodigal son coming back to
the internet moment
doing all of these projects over the
last five years in Legacy Media it's
been
it's been very rewarding and it's been
in many cases very fun and educational
but what I realized is that that's not
where
that's not what I love doing I love just
the Raw dynamism of
posting something getting immediate
feedback
processing that feedback understanding
like oh people like that why did people
like that
what is it about that idea that
resonates with people and then trying to
like figure out like okay well how could
I do something more with that I just I
love that process so much and the
immediacy and the creative control that
comes with that that I'm kind of
envisioning this place in my career is
like I'm coming back to that
I mentioned earlier that I'm I'm
currently hiring out a video team
and before like 500 people listening to
this
start setting the applications I can
learn I can learn Mark I'm willing to
work for free but you have to teach me
everything exactly
I have I've already made the initial
hires if there are more people that I'm
hiring subscribe to my newsletter it'll
be announced there
I'm very bullish on online media and
Independent Media in general and I think
it has a bright future I think it's It's
You could argue it's already the
predominant
form a media in terms of just where the
narratives come from and where the best
content comes from but I think it that's
only going to continue over the next
decade and so I'm excited to be here for
that you know I've there's two things
that I love one is what I just said the
kind of the immediacy of online content
the other one is just I have this very
very strong passion bordering on like
the fury of a thousand suns to take the
self-help World which traditionally you
know when I was growing up when you were
growing up self-help was not something
for the masses it was like if you if you
had a bunch of money in your savings and
could fly to a city and sit in a
conference room for five days like
that's that's where this content used to
be
and I think over the past 20 years we're
living through kind of I don't know if
democratizing is the right word but
just a widespread dissemination of these
very important Concepts and ideas to the
masses for either free or very very very
cheap
and I I just I really deeply believe
that a lot of these Concepts these basic
things that you and I talk about week in
week out
they should be everywhere they should be
taught in school they should be you know
basic relationship skills should be
taught in school basic meditation a lot
of the exercises you do in therapy CBT
like these Concepts should be taught
everywhere like everybody should have
access to them all the time and I'm very
passionate about that idea and I want to
that it's always been kind of like a
chip on my shoulder that I've had
throughout my career and it's still
there there's still work to do and so
the marriage of those two things is kind
of where my head is at right now
to choose the things you want to do
which you've been describing right to
hone in on the things that you know you
enjoy
it would seem to be that a prerequisite
of ensuring that happens I have a number
of follow-up questions this is one
ensuring that happens requires you say
no to a lot of stuff yes that you either
ignore completely don't respond to or
say no to a lot of stuff and you're
fortunate that you have a team so Molly
can also say no to a lot of things on
your behalf yes I'm curious
how you're thinking about saying no to
very tempting things and they may not be
tempting but I'll give you an example
okay so you get you get an email from
Molly she's like might be worth a five
minute conversation give me a call so
you get on the phone she's like Steven
Spielberg
you read well
he's not done this for anybody he wants
you to write a three-part oh God the
book series
[Laughter]
I'm already Facebook
and maybe I'm actually screwing up this
thought exercise by making a
three-parter no it's not a three-parter
but it is going to be
a year or two of focus on this which
would be the seminal definitive book
with Spielberg's full cooperation full
access journals everything pay you some
insane amount of money right twice the
number that you would pick as a stretch
goal that you're like they'll never say
yes to he's like I'll just pay twice as
much let's get this over with so we can
get to the work
what do you do when stuff like that
comes up because you know it's going to
come up well maybe I don't know maybe
not that specifically I'm using an
absurd goal
to drive the exercise yeah right because
if it's if it's like ah this is a B
minus offer easy to say no to right
because you want to strive to do an A
plus
in the things you just described so yeah
how do you think about saying no to the
stuff that will be
tempting
for lower level stuff I think the best
way is to Simply set rules
mm-hmm I've done that with speaking
the last year or two what are your rules
so my rules are basically it either
needs to be like
an Uber away or
it needs to be just like an absolutely
like stupid
amount of money
which nobody takes the stupid amount of
money so it's basically just an Uber
away and also I decided too that I'm not
really gonna do Keynotes anymore if you
want me to sit on stage and answer
questions that's fine but like the
preparation the thought the practice
that goes into a keynote the mental
energy like you're not getting paid for
60 Minutes on stage no you're getting
paid for everything around it exactly so
speaking has been a big one that that
I've cut out the Delta between how
speaking opportunities look on paper
versus reality is like it's just so wide
because you get that email and there's
this number with a bunch of zeros behind
it and you're like oh my God that's the
easiest money ever and then you actually
go do it and you're like wow I just
spent a week
not doing anything else to be here so
rules around that
so to the Spielberg opportunity you know
my my rule with any sort of like
celebrity Memoir would probably be very
similar to my role with Will
a-lister has to be doing it for right
reasons I think the difference this time
would be you know
part of the reason I
gave myself chest pains a few years ago
was I
I think I was so eager to say yes to
things
to back up a little bit after subtle art
there was a little bit of this
insecurity maybe call it imposter
syndrome of like okay this might be my
15 minutes say yes to everything because
yeah who knows if this is gonna
come back around who knows so I did that
I don't necessarily regret it but
I think this time around it would be on
my terms so it would be like okay
is he an a-lister yes he is is he doing
it for for the right reasons I'd
probably have to sit down and talk to
him get a feel for that
is it a good fit chemistry wise
you know have to sit down figure that
out and then I think it would be on my
terms I'd be like okay here's my
schedule for the next two years here's
where I can fit this in
this is when I'm available take it or
leave it I think the money at this point
would be a very very minor Factor
I've definitely only so many Skittles
you can eat seriously like it's you do
hit a certain number where you're like
[ __ ] it I'm just gonna do stuff I want
to do
yeah
so
very fortunate to be there
okay so let's say
miss you all Spielberg
it's like great that all sounds
fantastic
would it fit around what you just
described you would want to do or would
it start to crowd it out just knowing
yourself
if that offer came down the pipeline
like tomorrow
my reaction would be
I'm so I'm building out a video team
we're going to start scaling video
content in 2023
I'm under another contract with Harper
to do another book 2024
so we can get started like 2025 if you
want like that would probably be the
conversation which I'm sure he would
hate you know the challenge there would
be holding a line with that you know if
he started to push back and well we'll
offer you twice as much money as your
Harper contract you know it's like you
you can't get
seduced
like you need to hold it's it's like
boundaries and relationships right it's
like if you tell somebody like hey this
doesn't work for me don't do it and then
they do it
it's really hard to not let it slide
like nobody wants to to confront people
in their lives and say like hey that
like that that's upsetting to me I told
you not to do it you know it's really
hurtful that you did that like nobody
wants to have that conversation yeah but
if you want to have good relationships
you have to have that conversation and I
think it's the same in the professional
world like if you don't
set those boundaries of like okay this
is what works for me and if you don't
hold those boundaries yeah then you just
kind of end up in this
no man's land
furthermore if you don't
hold those boundaries if you make
exceptions
those exceptions are going to travel yep
and then people will either say you
don't actually follow your own rules so
you should say yes to my fill in the
blank
and most certainly because I've
experienced this and have become a lot
better at holding strong lines in the
last say 10 years
people will get pissed people will get
very pissed if you've said no to a bunch
then you say yes to one because for
whatever reason it's more appealing or
it just bleeds over into the maybe I
should let this slide category you can
really find yourself in just a world of
messiness
yes slogging through the swamp of
of unclear boundaries it's funny too
because
early in my career
I kind of prided myself on my ability to
say no to things that I didn't want to
do like that was kind of a badge of
honor I had what I didn't realize is
that as you scale the mountain
the things you have to say no to are
proportionally difficult to say no to
as how high you get so it's like you
it's like a skill you have to keep
learning over and over and over again oh
it absolutely is I mean the stuff you're
saying no to now
flashback not that long ago right
handful of years would have been the
best
they would have been offers that would
have exceeded your wildest dreams right
and these are the things you have to say
no to now it's a fun house mirror of
psycho-emotional experience because it's
not like we've let go of all of our
conditioning and hard wiring we've
developed over decades yeah it just
doesn't happen overnight let me fulfill
a promise to my audience because I did
say I was going to ask about it the the
subtle art cover
what is the background story on the
cover and how do you feel about it do
you like it when you first saw what
ended up being the cover
so I love the cover
to Harper's credit
they did it
good for them yeah it's funny because
when I went into that book that was you
know that was my first book with a
publisher all my friends
who were published authors had all these
warnings of like how horrible Publishers
are and how terrible mistake like
decisions they make and all this stuff
and
everything with subtle art was just a
breeze everything went really well
everybody got along there were no
problems and I was like wow what's
everybody talking about that's amazing
and I I will just highlight this is
extremely rare yes I just gave I'm not a
therapist I don't play one on the
Internet or I try not to but was just
doing my 100th iteration of like a three
hour therapy session with someone who's
going through their first book
experience yeah and I'm like I'm sorry I
I just I don't know what to tell you I'm
sorry this is this is the this is the
norm because he was like is this normal
this can't be normal does this actually
happen all the time and I was like yep
yep it's actually kind of obnoxious if
you get any amount of authors in a room
together
inevitably the conversation just always
ends up bitching about Publishers so the
funny thing about the cover though they
were very adamant on the orange so
initially it didn't have that splat
the Splat was me so I and this again
this is credit to them because this is I
didn't realize this was not normal so
they sent the initial draft of the cover
I took it put it like opened up
Photoshop myself I think I changed the
font to be the same font as my website
and then I added the Splat because I
wanted something kind of iconic it
seemed fitting and I sent it back to
them and they're like we love it it's
great we'll do it and I was like wow
great I love these guys and
you know sure enough you find out that
that never happens people never you know
the publisher never listens to your
feedback they try to force things
through but it it's actually ironic
because I think at the time I was just
this like no-name internet guy and so
they're like oh yeah well if that makes
them happy like let's just put it on the
cover
but then once you become
you know Mark Manson or Tim Ferriss or
Ryan holiday suddenly once they've got
the sunk cost of a real Advance now
things are a little different exactly
it's like everything is just murdered by
committee over and over again
ah what excites you these days and I'll
give you two options as a multiple
choice so what excites you these days I
think in part you've certainly answered
or alluded to that
and with video and the teams and I think
this is this is maybe me as a an avid
horse buggy driver in a world where a
Model T came out a few years ago and
everybody's moving to cars and I'm still
digging my horses trying to sell people
on why my horses are so incredible but
is the drive to video something that you
really want to do in your heart of
hearts or or and this is not a
pejorative
option b
is it because inevitably everything is
driving to video and that if you're not
capitalizing on that you are simply
going to be invisible to the algorithms
that matter and the results that matter
or something else it's a great question
and I'm not going to lie there is
definitely some of the latter in it of
just like I love this business I love
what I do and
like blogs are dead you and I both know
blogs are dead like you you get no reach
for any sort of written content
whatsoever
newsletters are getting super saturated
like it's just it's hard to
stay in front of eyeballs in our
industry that said
I wrestled with this this past year
because
I think it's been like four years now my
team has been telling me
dude you you either need to do videos or
have a podcast dude you either need to
have videos or have a podcast I'm like
[ __ ] I'm writing three books
right now like you can talk to me in two
years but they were right and I and I
knew they were right like it's just the
way the world is going so I I actually
dabbled a little bit with a podcast it
was funny
I went actually I think you have an old
article from years and years ago about
like the starter kit of equipment yeah
bought all that stuff I just wanted to
do like a dry run just to see do I enjoy
this is it fun for me
and actually my first guinea pig was was
our mutual friend Ryan holiday so I I
went over to his house down there in
Austin brought all the mics and
everything sat down
talked to him for an hour and a half two
hours
went home opened up the audio started
listening to it and I realized that it
was probably the least interesting
conversation Ryan and I had ever had in
our like five-year friendship that
immediately gave me a respect for what
you do and other podcasters do because
on the outside it looks like oh yeah you
just sit down and talk to somebody like
how hard is that you know like you don't
realize how much goes into being a good
interviewer
how much thought you have to put into
the questions you ask I usually have
this out of frame yeah yeah
it's not an accident it's not an
accident
I realized that it definitely wasn't
grabbing me
on the video side of things I initially
did it for the reason you just said I
was like well
having a YouTube channel just seems like
a thing you're supposed to have and so I
started recording some short videos
about two years ago and sent it off to a
freelance editor and kind of never
thought about it after that but as time
went on I started to
enjoy it more and more and I think the
thing with video is that there's
there is a very long learning curve to
it like you you have to understand it's
not just about being good on camera like
you need to understand lighting you need
to understand audio you need to
understand editing file types
resolutions aspect ratios like all this
stuff
and and usually the way you learn is by
[ __ ] it up first also YouTube right
like you have to pay attention to the
headlines the thumbnails
a million other variables right there's
a lot yeah so it's been a slow burn for
me but I think
it started to kind of become the
highlight of
whatever I was doing that month
okay this is interesting so how did that
shift happen how are you making it fun
for you
so I don't know if you run into this
much but one of the kind of the
frustrations I've started running into
is when it comes to personal development
topics there's nothing new Under the Sun
like all of these Concepts and ideas
yeah save for some recent psychological
research or you know every
couple times a year a really great new
study will come out in psychology
and then three years later it's not
replicated so it's like
most of what we're working with is ideas
and Concepts that have been around for
decades if not centuries footnotes to
Plato yeah right exactly everything is a
footnote to Plato there's only so many
ways you can
write about how to get over anxiety
before you just start repeating yourself
there's only so many ways you can write
about getting over a breakup before you
just start repeating yourself
and I I've definitely the last few years
I've felt like I've hit that
and
and it's been frustrating you know you
just you feel like you're trying to
reinvent the wheel all the time
and I feel like video
a new medium opens up opportunities to
approach
age-old topics from a new direction or
new dimension and that's kind of my plan
for that
I've become a lot more interested in
like okay I'm less interested in writing
about Theory and
you know this is how your mind works and
this is why you get anxious and this is
this is what resilience is and I'm much
more becoming far more interested in
implementation like okay how do you
actually get somebody who's read this
stuff to go do something with their life
and if you're limited to the written
form you can't really
do anything about that but if you've got
a camera with you like [ __ ] it go visit
the guy
see if he's getting off his couch film
it ask him how he's feeling you know
like I think there's just a lot of
opportunity to explore things in that
format
that haven't been tapped into and so
that's what really excites me at the
moment
the the new creative opportunities
in that sense
so it sounds like format wise
at least
that first blush as you're describing it
it's not going to be
Between Two Ferns with Mark Matson right
you won't be sitting down doing a video
what people might think of as a video
podcast necessarily you'll probably be
featured and part of the entire cocktail
that makes it work but do you envision a
lot of it being case studies so to speak
or
kind of real world
[Applause]
tracking of different people in a sense
I know tracking might be a strange word
so I think there's a lot of
keep in mind this is still super early
days for me but I've got a lot of
brainstorms around this right now so one
idea that I've talked to the team about
is
you can kind of reinvent classic psych
studies you know so there's a famous
marshmallow study like you could
probably do a really fun and
entertaining version of that with just
random people off the street and you
know give them 100 bucks if they win or
whatever I think there's a lot of
opportunity to do like a real-time you
can use things as incentive you can kind
of gamify it a little bit so I don't
know if you've watched like there's a
new trend going on on YouTube of like
kind of gamifying everything it's Mr
Beast got huge and everybody's yeah I've
seen Mr Beast for sure yeah so when I
was watching Mr B's I kind of the thing
that occurred to me was
okay well that's fun you know you put
people in a circle and see if how long
they can stay and then give them a
hundred thousand dollars whatever
whatever amount he he gives them like
what if you actually like took somebody
who
who's like struggled to lose weight over
the last five years and you're like hey
I'll give you I'll give you fifty
thousand dollars if you lose 20 pounds
in the next six months or whatever and
then you
track them and follow them and see
what's their process where do they get
hung up what are the self-defeating
beliefs and doubts and stuff like that
and I think this is what I like about it
too is that if you look at
you know research on
motivation and people actually sticking
to behaviors and goals and things like
that money is one of the most effective
super effective inputs it's like people
don't like to hear it but man do do
incentives work man yeah I mean it's
what's that Charlie Munger quote it's
like you know everything is incentive
yeah just follow the incentives yeah
just follow the incentives but yeah it
works it's just it's not scalable on
like a mass
you know you can't have like an army of
therapists who offer you a thousand
dollars to lose weight but you you can
have an [ __ ] on YouTube who does so
I'll be that [ __ ] and that's kind of
like the working concept at the moment I
think it will be fun but it also just
it makes it it renews the subjects for
me you know I've been beating these dead
horses for 15 years at this point and
you know this brings the horse back to
life yeah and I think it also just
introduces a lot of these Concepts and
ideas to to a new generation you know
there's gen Z is not on Twitter they're
not reading blogs they're not signing up
for newsletters they're on YouTube
they're on tick tock
so that excites me as well
yeah I dig it I love I love that you're
tweaking and brainstorming to keep it
fun and interesting for yourself I've
seen so many examples of YouTubers who
have
created a style
very successful style they've been
cursed with
getting a lot of attention and
ultimately a lot of money for creating a
caricature of themselves that they then
have to continue to be yeah and
the question therefore of how do you do
this in a way that is
energy giving fun
creatively satisfying on some level
without just being the nth person to
come up with
a
20-second dance routine on Tick Tock
hoping that you're going to ride that
wave yeah and if that's not something in
a million years you would ever want to
do otherwise
yeah I feel like I have a couple
competitive advantages entering that
space in a serious way I feel like I
have a couple of competitive advantages
for the simple fact that I'm old
because most big YouTubers are like
they're 20 something year old dudes who
have never had a real job
never been married don't have kids I
feel like as somebody who has been doing
this for a long time and has got who has
fallen into a lot of those traps of
feeling like you have to please the
audience all the time or feeling like
you have to publish all the time
or being terrified that
You Know You're Gonna Lose people or
they're going to leave you or whatever
like you know I I've I've gone through
that in my own way and I I feel like
I've got my head on straight about it at
this point and then
I also just think it's an advantage to
be older and know who you are be in a
position where it's like well it's like
the Spielberg thing right it's like well
you know dude I
I got enough Skittles thanks but
I don't need your views thank you
yeah you also are in the enviable
position of
having the ability to do
a huge range of experiments yeah right
because you have sort of the time and
space if you choose to create it and
protect it you have resources so if you
wanted to do
something out there that might cost a
pretty penny but you can afford to lose
it you can do that so it's a great
position to be in I'm excited for you a
couple of boring tactical questions do
you still use scrivener when working on
your books or do you use other workflow
I use scrivener for the first draft of
my first two books or for subtle art and
for everything is [ __ ]
I find it great for
if you still haven't quite nailed down
the organization of a book scrivener is
great for moving around large chunks of
text very easily
but it's actual user interface I think
is is inferior to word so if you're
actually trying to go line by line and
just make everything really polished and
clear I think word so usually I would do
first draft on scrivener and then Port
it over to word and do all my revisions
onward and go from there
Sophie's World
so I have read I don't know if you still
feel this way this is from
an interview on pneumaticmat.com
from a while back
and
it has here you can't believe everything
you read on the internet so feel free to
confirm deny or modify but if you're a
complete newbie to philosophy and want
to get a basic understanding of the
western Canon I recommend a book called
Sophie's World by Justine Garder I want
to say it's a fun fiction book that acts
as a kind of primer or primer
depending on how fancy you want to get
to the most important Western thinkers
is that still a book you would recommend
yes with the asterisk that I read it as
a teenager it is a fun way to get I
would say like a Wikipedia understanding
of each major thinker and their
contributions and how they influenced
Western Civilization which writers or
thinkers or
let's
stick with writers first
and we can then talk about other people
who might be influencing your thinking
but are there any particular writers or
books
that
you have been paying particular
attention to in recent memory I can buy
some time by giving examples okay I
would say there are the long-standing
influences
which we don't necessarily have to focus
on
but we could if they're still highly
relevant to you
in your life now so for instance I
believe that you've mentioned David
Foster Wallace Joan Didion Hunter S
Thompson
and others Stephen Pinker Jonathan
height
in my particular case for instance I've
had a number of books recommended to me
only one of the three of which I've read
so that would be I believe it's 4 000
weeks by Oliver Berkman which I thought
was a fantastic book and there are a
number of chapters that really stuck out
as counter-intuitively helpful such as
Cosmic insignificance therapy which I
ended up excerpting on the blog because
I wanted to share with people and share
the book with people
then there's another which I suspect I
will find interesting which is called
die with zero
which is by I believe Bill Perkins I
have not read it yet but these are books
that seem to cohere in
a puzzle of life philosophies and
instructions that I think will be very
relevant to me now and over the next say
five years so I'm paying attention
to
those books and the threads that appear
to connect them
I'm also paying attention because I'm
working on fiction right now
in this highly absurd but very very fun
series of
World building exercises that I'm doing
in fantasy actually so it's very
different from anything I've ever done
if people want to take a look it's the
project is called [ __ ] punch and you can
find it online anywhere so go to
cockpunch.com and I bought that URL I
tried to get on your white list but it
was impossible
yeah it was surprisingly
I think surprisingly
surprisingly popular there was a lot of
demand there's a lot of fun coming so
that is an example of me doing something
for the pure [ __ ] Joy of it yeah and
I'm having a lot of fun with that
at the same time I can study say Ursula
K Le Guin and these classic iconic
highly skilled masters of The Craft
whether that be fantasy or science
fiction so I'm paying attention to
for instance the writer's Journey which
is effectively the hero's journey
adapted but applied to writing so those
are the examples personally of things
that are currently on my mind and I've
also realized that I've been over
caffeinating and
inflicting biological anxiety on myself
in a very unnecessary way so I'm going
to be revisiting
some of the stoic writings probably the
moral letters to lucillius by Seneca
which is commonly sold through I think
penguin Classics as
letters from stoic so that would be a
very long
word salad of
books that are currently on my mind
gotcha right there's like there's like
one that's kind of anchoring to two more
I want to read and then with the craft
that I'm currently involved with let's
call that fiction a few things a tie
into that okay yeah it's hard because
it's I mean there's so many books to
talk about there are a lot of books so a
lot of books
but yeah I mean you you definitely hit
what I would consider my biggest
influences you know David Foster
Wallace's non-fiction
is what made me want to be a writer
he's got particularly his piece a
supposedly fun thing I'll never do again
is just
I go back and read it every couple years
and then just in awe of how clever and
observant he is
Hunter's Thompson Joan Didion you know I
I kind of think there's there's almost
like different categories in my brain so
there's there's non-fiction writers I
appreciate for the quality of their
writing which they are in there is
non-fiction
I would call it academic nonfiction
which I mostly read just to
make sure I'm
understand the prevalent research in the
space
which would be Jonathan hate I'm a huge
fan of Dan Gilbert he's got a great book
called stumbling on happiness yeah
excellent book yeah it's such an in my
opinion it's kind of the best book about
happiness research in all the paradoxes
and contradictions that come with it
and then in another category I guess you
would call it like contemporaries so I I
also love berkman's book I'm actually
friends with Oliver he and I used to be
meditation buddies in New York no
kidding small world and he sent me a
draft of that for a blurb and it was my
email back to him was like
it was like
you you [ __ ] man like this is this is
one of every once in a while you read a
book and you're just kind of you're a
little bit angry because you're like I
wish I wrote this because it's that good
and it's that smart
and I was like yeah this is that for me
like I'm I'm I'm happy for you I'm so
happy for you but there's a little piece
of me that's like [ __ ]
very well written yeah it's fantastic so
you know stuff that you or Ryan or James
Clear
people kind of in this new personal
development space I'm always tracking in
terms of just like what I've been
reading recently
I've actually been reading a lot of
fiction the last year I I am not
gonna start writing fiction unlike you
anytime soon maybe one day it's actually
kind of like a bucket list thing to do a
novel one day but
it's funny again coming out of this
intense period of work I it's almost
like my brain just
it would seem kind of repulsed by a lot
of non-fiction you're like I like dark
chocolate but I've had it five times a
day for the last three years I needed a
break from dark chocolate seriously man
I mean I read you know both in terms of
research and also just my own curiosity
I read hundreds and hundreds of books
non-fiction books over that period And I
think coming out of it you know as soon
as I didn't feel like I had to read
those for a project anymore I was like
my brain was like all right give me
fantasy give me no more homework no more
homework yeah
what kind of fiction
so I'm actually trying to get back to
kind of lighter fiction
Stephen King is is one of those authors
that obviously I've always heard of him
always know about him I read a couple of
his books in high school loved them and
then never really went back to him and
so now that I'm kind of on this like
decompression
reading kick
I've taken upon myself to go to actually
go back and read some of the Stephen
King classics
I read this is not fiction but it was a
biography I read Unbroken by Lauren
hillebrand about the World War II
incredible story right I've been reading
a lot of World War II stuff all the
light you cannot see is fantastic I'm
kind of on a light fiction kick just
like letting my brain recover yeah and
maybe it's also because I'm in a Zone in
my career that's very open and creative
right now and I kind of want to just be
able to let any idea in and play with it
um so maybe that's why it feels right
as thinking of
easy to read fiction that I've enjoyed
in the last few years uh
if you wanted to read especially if you
never have read a hard-boiled Detective
fiction novel that I thought was
incredibly hilarious and came highly
recommended the last good kiss by James
Crumley
c-r-u-m-l-e-y some of the languages
dated I'll warn people in advance so
trigger warning but
it is
as as it says in its description on
Amazon one of the most influential crime
novels ever written by a legend of the
genre it's hilarious and the the writing
is is very strong so James Crumley the
last good kiss would be pretty high up
and I'll give you one other different
genre just in case you want to screw
around
this is I'll give you two so on the
Sci-Fi side
either of the anthologies by Ted Chang
c-h-i-a-n-g
man those are just incredibly strong
it's unbelievable yeah I read both of
his collections
I want to say three or four years ago
yeah it just floored me I was like so
good speechless afterwards yeah
incredible and so along those I don't
say same lines because each of his short
stories is so different but
there is a book called This is how you
lose the time War
and part of what makes it so cool is
that it was written by two people who
alternated chapters as they went along
but it is it is entirely cohesive so how
you even do that interesting is almost
Beyond Comprehension I can see how you
could have a writing partner and you
work on a screenplay together but to
write a super compelling sci-fi novel
that is kind of a category breaking
format in and of itself deeply
sophisticated and
time bending
with two authors is something else and
it's a fast Read Super compelling
anyway I'll throw that one out just as
uh as an option if amongst the 100 other
books you're reading you're looking for
101st
that's well Mark this has been a really
fun conversation we have covered a lot
I don't feel the need to try to bleed
the stone I think people will will find
at least a few stories a few tidbits in
this that they can walk away with and
Ponder or use in some fashion is there
anything else you'd like to say any
closing comments questions anything
you'd like to point my audience to
anything at all that you'd like to add
no I mean just the usual like
go to my website read my [ __ ] type thing
I I do want to say thank you to you I I
seriously it's I mean you've been
a Pioneer for my generation and you know
been a big fan for a long time my
adolescent anger towards you aside while
I was sleeping on couches seriously
you've
for for those of us who are
the generation under you you've been
showing us how to do it for a long time
now so I appreciate that oh thanks man I
really appreciate that
and it's been
it's been really fun to
see you on this rocket ship and it's
been very fun for me to have this
conversation also because I've wondered
often like I wonder how the [ __ ] he's
feeling about all this like what is this
experience like I wonder what the
experience might be to be in his shoes
right now so it's been fun to to get a a
peek on the inside and to to hear it
straight from the man himself so I I
really do appreciate it everybody you
can find all of Mark at markmanson.net
the new redesign is beautiful it's very
elegant it's very clean I've been
thinking of doing a complete redesign on
my site for the first time in a long
time and went to your site just in the
course of doing research for this
conversation I was like wow that's clean
that's clean the old design is like
eight years old and it was funny because
as soon as the first drafts of this new
one came in
me and my developer like went and looked
at the old site and we were just
horribly embarrassed we were like how
how have we allowed this to be online
so onward and upward you're trending in
the right direction I look forward to
seeing the video I look forward to
seeing the film also so keep an eye out
folks that'll be released in theaters by
Universal Pictures wild who would have
thought crazy back when you were working
on teeth whitening and feng shui
it's so fun it's so I find it so
inspirational
to track those things from the very
early Beginnings because you can't
possibly if you if you had sat down and
maybe you did when working on all those
many sites and throwing everything
against the wall and tried to form a
10-year plan that would get you here it
would have been impossible never it just
wouldn't have worked it's like the Steve
Jobs thing where you can connect the
dots going back like I look back and
it's yeah all those kind of [ __ ] SEO
sites
I needed those to kind of build up the
skill set to actually build a
functioning company and a Blog that got
an audience and then from there you
learn the skills had to expand the
audience and like you said it's the
it's the tacky ball yeah it's the tacky
ball the Katamari damashi
the clump Spirit
sounds better in Japanese yeah well Mark
I really appreciate the time thank you
for taking it and being so open to
discussing all the things
really really do appreciate the time and
appreciate what you're trying to do in
the world and what you are doing in the
world so keep it up
and to everybody listening until next
time one step at a time keep that sticky
ball rolling and don't underestimate
what you can do over time
and try not to overestimate what you can
do in a given week or a month because
you'll just end up beating the [ __ ] out
of yourself and that does not tend to
help you in the long term so be just a
little bit Kinder than is necessary
to not just others but to yourself and
thanks for tuning in